l una il tifo e work is the story of c'è
stata una piena cercando gli alberi
ebbene madagascar questo è una scena di
nasca visto ieri gran film terza olibea
iron noi scholten in crescita a livello
la che passa davanti a un lucernaio è
fatto bene cacchio è carino cioè che
riflesso giorno 6 su un pavimento a
scacchi
volendo possiamo giocare sei pezzi ma
che stilerà che è molto simile all inter
nightmares sbaglio o è molto più club
l'inter michaels no dico questo perché
dalla inquadra dall'inquadratura cima
c'è un sedime larga sono io sono un
bambino è suonato in un grazie teddy
bear che però gustavo corali gustavo è
veramente ritel nightmares questo qua
c'è proprio e proprio ispirato aiuto
madonna mi sono mi sono ammazzato per un
niente
ma ragazzi mi ha fatto benissimo parte
fatto che è partito super crisi ma
proprio i perché
io correrei di sopra poi fai il bravo
gustavo bravo
mammamia gustavo ti amo ti amo io ti amo
cazzo a mi segue anche perfetto delivery
usavo vieni è fatto benissimo per fatto
benissimo mi stupì giocare in the light
manners pazzesco no ragazzo male mi
manca un po la falda guarda sempre un
tipico piatto che cucino io di solito io
ti lancio sopra il carrello e tu stai
fermo facciamo suo gioco va bene non
pensavo di essere shaquille o'neal ma
alle buche ma bellissimo bellini fatto
da dio speriamo che abbiano fatto anche
il gioco intero sento rumori comunque
veramente crisi c'era un sacco di sangue
gustavo aiuta me pareva posto ciò quando
lui tanto non gliene è fregato niente
dava per scontato che mi sarei salvato
lei ha detto va bene come succede
succede lo vai perché torni indietro che
succede gustavo ti sei una mano ti
spingo faccio io a posto
il personaggio è stranissimo c'è un
cappello che non hanno senso mi sono
svegliato in questa casa con un cencio
svegliato e roland nicchiato nel
pavimento e non so per quale motivo è
perché c'è un orsacchiotto che ha vita
propria
che cos'è questo gioco incredibile aiuto
mi sono salvato non so come mi porta
anche la carta igienica vini che serve
la prendiamo gustavo per questo serve
sempre solo due i giochi horror
prendiamo questo bravo rossi però vabbè
ci metto due ore a [ __ ] peccato
perché i rotolini agirà non finiscono
mai ma questo è finito per l'ho buttato
direttamente sotto ci sono un po di tubi
il paradiso del tubo youtube parola
merda c'è solo sto braccio tra l'altro
ma che cazzo è chi sei
il corpo di notizie qui vuol dire che i
due ore non ti sei mosso e quello tra
mancato come cazzo ha fatto col riciclo
ma mancato come come cazzo fate così
storto zio ero fermo
dovevo scappare due ore prima ero fermo
fermo
ma cosa c'è spiegate nella sta roba e
donando ac ci diamo una mano ci dà certo
certo faccio io gustavo che faceva segno
di lanciarlo la un capito capito
ok forse ma deve crollare non deve
crollare tutto sono poi non sai proprio
ok
e allora andiamo fratello labview
proprio lui proprio lui quello di qua
bellissimo diventata in 3d la tensione
fra te mi sa che quando va a fare
qualcosa insieme tipo che tu devi andare
laggiù in qualche modo di lancio di
questa volti lancio filanti prende
bilancio
no scherzavo è troppo distante devo
prima alzare sta cosa vai vai vai vai
fratello vai non c'è molta voglia di
andare devono premere il tasto y il
tristissimo va bene vai vai vai
sull'altro cosa mai su un altro costo
frate bravo esco una donna che squadra
siamo sì
vai vai rischio grazie caro non ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta giornata giocata
giocatori ce l'ha fatta ci ha fatto mai
letti latina tira bravo proprio loro la
costruiscono madonna che figo è
bellissimo gioco fate legio ix successo
ci passo lo stesso le slot ci passo ci
passo è un gioco spaziale è un gioco
spaziale è bellissimo c'è alcun e alcuni
pezzi mi fanno più godere di intel light
marsico questo è pazzesco perché c'è
sott'acqua
no quella la nuvola che dove vecchio
siamo la che sott'acqua supporto sì
forse sì forse siamo tipo in un tempio
sommerso gustavo corri corri se se se
the miti a due anni gustavo e stato
bellissimo sono usciti o e adesso adesso
è meglio che è un po più allegri si può
passare anche da fuori lo vedi no e poi
vengono adesso mi aprì la porta se di
lancio dentro la prima porta apriva la
porta ma bravo gustavo bravo così mi
piace spaccatutto porco 36 gustavo usavo
gus gus miss mousse mus e finito eccolo
cosa guardi se gli fai poi fatta più la
porta e salire così velocemente che
cartacei superpoteri sapete già che se
non sai 8 che si muove non è
hai visto tutto sto casino per guardare
l'orizzonte n'è valsa la pena comunque
perché madonna che figo siamo su
un'isola
ma cos'è c'è un modo c'è un faro non
hanno né a molla so fare questa che
bella la nostra amicizia
ti voglio bene non ti lascerò mai meno
male che c'è alle barriere invisibili è
stato bellissimo finora scoperta allora
fino qua tutto bene che non è per niente
scontato vedi se riesci a tirare la
luiss perfetto bravo madonna che scuola
mamma mia ma è comunque mi sembra di
essere tornati ai tempi a way out ma lui
è molto più bravo del di ciccio merino
dal mio aiuto che questa incredibile
perché è un npc è uno scherzo decisione
ma c'è andy bravo bus
così si fa cacchio e usa usa usa e cosi
uso e cosa vai vai vai vai col santo
iddio bene no no troppo troppo che cazzo
fai bravo spaccato un urto spacca mica
bus dei fatti valere caso butta giù
tutto brown zio bellissimo con crea con
che atteggiamento poi se n'è fregato
niente
bravo go6 tutto tuo fratello comunque
devo andare di qua
da lì sopra le strade c'è un
ambientazione ragazzi l'ambientazione
pazzesca ma che gioco pazzi questo anche
mi ricorda le miniere di moria quella
media evil va bene
no no no no no gustavo gustavo no no no
ti prego mica mi stavo vivendo benissimo
ti prego no ragazze bellissime ti prego
vi prego deve uscite lo uscite il gioco
non possa abbandonare il mio gustavo non
lo posso fare
quindi quando esce questo gioco ditemelo
voglio giocando tutta la vita bellissimo
bellissimo queste sono le avventure del
mio e del mio amico gustavo spero vi
siano piaciute fatemi sapere se volete
il gioco completo quando uscirà io
personalmente ci perché se come na
figata pazzesca
niente ci vediamo questi episodi
ispirati al canale lascia un argomento e
ragazzi
[Musica]